we look at just do simple sets in this
video set P which has one two and three
as its elements and set Q which has one
two three four and five has its elements
understand the elements well this has
one two and three and this one has one
two three four and five this is a part
of this and that's why we say set P is a
part of set Q and we learned in the
previous video that part of also means
subsets so we can say that set P is a
subset of set Q do we have a symbol to
represent this yes it's written like
this P is a subset of Q the letter U is
sleeping on this line so when is P a
subset of a you set P is a subset of set
Q when every element in P is also
present in Q look at the elements every
element in P is also present in Q but
this statement raises a new query look
at set C and D set C has four five and
six as its elements and set D has four
six and five as its elements both the
sets have the same elements which makes
them equal but every element in set C is
also present in set D based on the
definition we can say that set C is a
subset of set D this also tells us
something more it tells us that every
set is a subset of itself P is a subset
of P Q is a subset of Q and so on for
some reason this does not seem entirely
correct and that give rise to a new
concept of proper subsets look at sets P
and Q set P is a part of set Q but there
is at least one element in set Q which
is not press
and in set B we say that set B is a
proper subset of set Q this sign
indicates proper subset and this tells
us that all elements of P are present in
set cube but there is at least one
element in Q which is not present in P
we can see that 4 and 5 are not present
in P so that's the concept of a proper
subset sometimes it is also referred to
as the strict subset can we say C is a
proper subset of D think about it that
would be incorrect since there is no
element in D which is not a part of C
there has to be at least one such
element that's the only difference
between a subset and a proper subset
just one last thing we need to
understand just as we say P is a proper
subset of Q we can also say that set Q
is a superset of SEC P this symbol is
used to represent superset
you